there you go sorry that was tasteless
and racist um louis c.k special and the
controversy you were about to go ahead
yeah I think it's a hilarious special
it's on the heels of like Bill burr and
Chapelle Dave Chappelle came out with
one and now Louis comes out with one and
all of the woke people are so upset
about this thing not only is the
material very politically incorrect he
dares use the R word in it it's just
recidivism tool if I may say yeah and
and what you're getting is what most
people find hilariously funny from a guy
that did nothing in my opinion he asked
permission to you know do something in
front of a couple of girls that was
alright a little odd a little weird game
should be held liable for us for that
but it was like it was like the
real-life version of chatroulette and
it's creepy and it's gross but let's not
compare it to Roman Polanski or Harvey
Weinstein right or Bill Cosby or a
number of other people that are absolute
actual rapists you know instant all
messed up though he's got the corona
like we needed you comic the way that I
watched you is what they hate about him
is he's able to survive without them not
only all-time millionaire without them
and when you watch the special he was so
heavily criticized for something you're
saying about shootings and everything
yeah you can tell that when he put the
special out it was deliberately meant to
just offend all the people that hadn't
had been bothering him for twenty years
that's what I loved it was a great one
our middle finger to everyone
yeah cuz he he doesn't care he's
self-sufficient and now you're getting
people though that say he shouldn't he
shouldn't have a career he shouldn't be
allowed to do that anyone that
downloaded his special is is culpable in
in in rape shaming and it's so
ridiculous and I hope that that our
priorities change after this whole thing
doubt it will but it would be nice about
priorities change we didn't hear so much
about all the garbage and nonsense that
was eating up the news and our personal
lives and people being cancelled for
just ridiculous stuff they're chewing
about louis ck's special that's self
produced and released i don't hear
anyone calling for an embargo on
Margaret Cho coming in at this point
that's a national security issue at this
point uh yeah you know we get it your
mom has an accent I never thought yeah I
never saw do that in her act where she
does an impression that if anyone else
did it they would be exiled to be
similar to like the old impressionist
like rich you know rich little it like
this is what I imagine it would be like
if you know Ronald Reagan chopped a
zucchini you know anything you want to
watch Margaret Cho special it's like did
you know how my mom would react to
coronavirus times - I've worked on my
chil great Margaret Jo I know I know I
just you know and I just I don't know I
can't I can't control it
I don't know what's gonna happen next
it's like Margaret it's so random you
know it's like Robin Williams it's
random but it's actually all pre-written
at the same set so when when this when
this antibody test comes out we're gonna
find out that a hell of a lot of people
have already gone through corona well
this is interesting to me because they
don't want to find a silver lining in
anything and again not to diminish that
the virus of course and I think if
nothing else has taught us where we have
our weak spots in certain global
organizations that shouldn't be trusted
like the World Health Organization if
you see what they've done with Taiwan so
there could be a silver lining
politically obviously but as far as
chloroquine they don't want to
acknowledge that when they say oh my
gosh it turns out that over 25% of
people of corona are asymptomatic
and 80 something percent have very mild
symptoms I go okay so there's some and
that means that I could be carrying it
to other people means that 90% of people
could be carrying it to the 10% who have
more than the sniffles but isn't it a
good thing like you don't shut
the entire global economy through summer
I want the mayor from Abbeville from
Jaws to come out and tell them he's not
closing down New York for the 4th of
July weekend he's the guy right those
beaches will be okay that nobody cares
about that none of founders of wayne
singer the Stacy's mom guy call me when
Paul Simon gets Corona I'm sorry at a
certain point in that movie she should
be dead she's 91 years old wait how
could those beaches will be open I want
that Corona that coronavirus found and
hung up by its Buster Brown we're gonna
need a bigger vaccine what does no
vaccine okay so no vaccine no nother but
like you said good news be damned they
cannot they cannot have good news and
I've been reading tweets from all the
networks yeah I'm a pump out and you
read all of their horse crap and one one
that I saw it was like they talked to
over a half dozen doctors about
something it's like that's seven yeah it
was anything what is setting tonight
more people and then they say there's
zero evidence for chloroquine out there
well no there are hundreds of people
involved across multiple clinical sites
and by the way six thousand doctors
signed a form saying it's the most
effective treatment right now Wolf
Blitzer spoke with seven people who by
the way we're nurses in doctors uniform
which is a problem like I've talked
about I I don't like that at all I don't
like when they were male nurse
practioner yes yeah I don't like when
the male nurses get in front of the
camera and talk like a doctor now look I
know nurses look I'll preface it like
you just did before
I know they are eros they are some of
the smart but I
by the way that the nurses are the ones
that actually do the surgeries yes
absolutely
the NYPD should get on their knees for
male nurse practitioners absolutely yes
exactly they're the important people
that save lives
yes but the guys that actually went to
medical school for umpteen years they're
not the heroes now it's somebody that
went to I don't know Phoenix online
Phoenix online you Maury and a guy yells
at you for not going to a crappy college
you got a free stethoscope upon your
graduation right yeah I never know what
we're talking about okay let's go back
to the comm did you have a point we
didn't one of us have a point about this
before you got you said we're gonna
preface it and then you just insulted I
and I was gonna preface the the doctor
and nurse thing yep from what I'm
hearing it there aren't as many patients
in a lot of these hospitals they've set
up they've set them up in Central Park
here in New York City and that we have
the hospital ship and we have the Javits
Center and it was supposed to be all
these were supposed to be overflow we
haven't seen any video like we were
seeing from China what happened in China
where people were just collapsing in the
street and convulsing what happened like
in China where people had to be dragged
into vehicles and driven off to
god-knows-where those were the
whistleblowers and the convulsing was
from the dart gun exactly where is just
like anything else yet when they did the
news when they do the news and a
blizzard is coming they go oh boy this
is gonna be the blizzard of the century
it's gonna be the worst storm ever and
as it approaches you'll see they go well
um where are our models are showing us
that the snowfall won't be as great but
the wind and ever it's gonna be a blazer
it's gonna be crazy and then when when
zero hour comes they go we sure dodged
that bullet didn't we right god right
last thing they want is it dodged a
bullet
they hate dodging bullets they want the
task or feel the bullet written here oh
yeah right through you and that's what
this is they they made this the big
zombie movie monster thing that everyone
was afraid of and it's
turn out to be like the flu people die
people get sick well it'd be fair I
think it's it's thinking here's the
thing for people who are compromised
it definitely is more severe than the
flu but I said what a long time ago I
said of course how about we quarantine
older people people who are vulnerable
so here at the office you know this has
been I won't lie it's been a rough
couple weeks for me because we've
actually doubled shows who are doing
morning and night shows because we
wanted to give people more content out
there I know they're getting a little
bit stir-crazy my mother who you know
she actually did the the costumes for
just for laughs for about a decade so
she's our costume person here and she
has pneumonia so what we did was we said
you go don't we'll have just sort of a
piece someone here help us with wardrobe
and we make sure that I don't go
anywhere near my dad so he does so
that's what we've done we've done and
everyone else who's young and healthy no
symptoms if you're working in close
proximity we wear masks we disinfect not
saying no one here will get sick but
everyone's been fine and everyone still
has gainful employment which we had a
conversation here people said there's an
acceptable risk and we would like to
work so there does it but that there is
the same approach being taken kind of
like if you say you know what listen I
believe that there's a climate change I
believe that that has occurred I believe
that maybe humans are contributing to it
I don't know the severity and I don't
think that these policies will change it
politically in people act as though your
science and I are even if you say the
virus is real I think we need to take
precautions I just don't think that
right now this is a balanced approach
they sent they just lambaste you as anti
science you have to be on either end of
the spectrum you can't be anywhere in
the middle you have to be this is the
worst thing everyone in the world is
gonna die or on the other end saying we
should just run around coughing in each
other's faces anywhere in the middle and
you're denying some someone's opinion of
science right you should have a thirteen
year old girl come and tell us about and
then I would be more right with grades
from a Norwegian sort of Nordic you know
what's so funny I'm so tired
I had forgotten the reference to Greta I
was thinking you were going to like to
capture Joe Biden's attention because
he's a pedophile you would love to sniff
her breathe the way I put that on a hook
if I wanted to meet them
just Jo like way like Yogi Bear with a
picnic basket pied mill they just put a
dangle of child you're talking about the
presumptive Democratic nominee for the
presidency rats okay even if he saw this
he wouldn't understand
final question woods so obviously you're
in a little bit of a different set here
you two are roomies right now so that's
cute um how are you spending your time
during the the quarantine how has it
changed how you guys do your show
it's really something as far as I'm
concerned it hasn't changed much for me
I don't go into the city so I'm not
taking the train in and walking through
the the petri dish that is Penn Station
and going into the studio right so it's
a couple hours here every day but after
that my life has not really changed much
because all I did was come home I'd
watch some TV I'd play some video games
I'd you know talking my girl we'd hang
out pet the cats but going to pull I up
the pole fired up ready to go nice but
but other than that like I don't
normally go out here's the one thing I
do miss going out to dinner like I am
like going out to restaurants having a
nice wine and a nice filet mignon and
like that was that sue pregnant some
living pinky mice will be more offended
at what you said just their work none of
us do it it's an entire country that
does it they look the dog in the eye
while eating it alive the first like
that is nothing compared to when they
try and trace the sociopathic behavior
of Jeffrey Dahmer like before he raped
man and eat them oh he put ants under a
magnifying glass
he didn't boil dogs alive sorry that was
racist
[Laughter]
it's so I mean doing the show I like it
much better like this then then doing
the the Skype all the time right between
a host and a co-host Skype it's a little
awkward we have the guys in the city
doing the show in the studio that live
in the city they're able to get there
and do the show there so we're pretty
much up and running with all of our
programming being live because yeah like
you said people are clamoring for
something yeah you know there's there's
not much out there
we've just been experiment this morning
we did an entire broadcast of just I
have a dog that's obsessed with toilet
paper a big old she looks like a Great
Dane with a pit bull at a babe it's
called a Doug origin Tino and we just
did a 30-minute broadcast we set up a
tower of toilet paper like a champagne
Tower and just let her destroy it for a
half-hour and provide like golf
commentary and it pissed off more people
than anything else we've ever done
due to the toilet paper shortage you
could have donated it but you know what
I can't save everyone but I can make one
dog's day and that's what I did that's
great you're not going to see that's
almost like a reverse Warriors you know
they had to make the route to Coney
while avoiding the baseball Furies but
you're like trying to make your way into
Manhattan avoiding the microbes and you
know just facepalm a bunch of Asians and
masks yeah I'd rather have to make my
way here in Roslyn Long Island to the
liquor store
yeah which put in a window that my
liquor store put in a window with a
little buzzer and the transaction
happens okay separately through a window
you stand outside so I really appreciate
that because alcohol has pretty much
been the savior during this whole thing
whether you're rubbing it into your
hands or pouring it into your liver
alcohol and corona are like peas and
carrots yeah you can start drinking the
sanitizer yeah it's like what's-her-name
Dukakis Oh
yeah you know well you know what I did
and then we do it we do actually have to
go I could talk with you guys all day
and Anthony I owe you an appearance on
your show by the way you just so happen
to ask when we started doubling the show
content Oh
but right after I had heard about so I'm
not a doomsday prepper
but I've always have 30 days of food
like dehydrated food I always have some
water and another thing that I was that
people talk about your sort of bug out
bag I always have at least a couple
bottles of Everclear and the reason why
is if something really goes down it's
you know you can drink it it's a trading
commodity it's also not toxic and if you
dilute it enough it has to be diluted
enough it can be a sanitizer well the
CDC came out and said don't make hand
sanitizer out of any homemade liqueurs
and by name they listed Everclear and
said because it's not effective enough
unless it's 60% I'm going my Everclear
is 92 percent alcohol I have a diluted
and then a week later they go I guess
Everclear can work if you want to waste
the money I didn't ask you to manage my
finances it's actually cheaper than
sanitizer I asked you if Everclear would
work in a pandemic to sanitize so if
people out there cuz now I've stocked up
have if you want one item that saves
space you can also use it for a few a
few la I'll call burning stove I yeah
ever clear is the best option you have
and no one thought of it in the first
few weeks so yeah there you go yeah I
have my go-bag all loaded up ready to go
a couple of a couple of rifles
strategically placed around the house
and you know all ready to go here on
beautiful Nassau County Long Island I'm
germaphobic dirty had all that stuff I
had masks that was already ready and now
I'm staying with him so if I need a gun
they're everywhere perfect and then if
one of you runs out of masks will have
some tryouts okay it is the COO Mia show
Anthony Kamiya compound Mediacom it's a
enter the promo code compound 20 right
that's the 20% of them okay at 20% off
thanks man thank you guys appreciate it
and we're doing so much more content now
if you're up early we do the good
morning mug Club I'm sure we can have
you on here sometime the next month
absolutely I love what you're doing man
you guys are so funny and like I said
that that piece and it's like other
things you do when you go to those when
you were going to the college campuses
before all this crap started right I
love those things where you just sit
down and people lose their minds
with the fact that you just want to have
a discussion I can't get over those y3
[ __ ] and I I still listen I still listen
to a lot of your stuff and by the way
hey let Artie Lange know that we would
love to have him on the show
i'm reaiiy don't think I've ever been
rooting for someone more I don't think I
know I think I can say this now on air
I've only ever edited two interviews in
my life okay cuz we often pre-tape based
on time one of them was a friend who
will admit just because he was so boring
but so sweet and meandering and the
other one was Artie because now we can
he was clearly high and he said some
things that it didn't make sense and I
thought could get him into a lot of
trouble so I said you know what let's
cut that before air and let his manager
know I don't think Artie would ever even
remember because it was a really
tumultuous period of his life for me and
his new TRT regimen don't think we're
not noticing NIC you and your goat in
law song even thanks so much thank you
very much Anthony we appreciate and
thank you Dave thank you guys we'll have
you back on soon we're gonna wrap the
show up in a nice bow like the dog in
your pan
[Music]